y
[Música]
el líder demócrata en el senado de eeuu
choque somero anunció que llegaron a un
acuerdo con los republicanos para evitar
el cierre de gobierno o soft down en el
que estaba en riesgo de caer el país si
no aprobaba el presupuesto para el
siguiente año fiscal mañana les
explicamos en esta misión
aumenta la atención entre francia y
reino unido- en londres sólo aprobó 12
de las 47 licencias solicitadas por
pescadores galos para trabajar en aguas
del canal de la mancha parís calificó la
decisión de inaceptable y aseguró que
infringe el acuerdo de break shit
francia rindió un homenaje póstumo al
sargento que falleció en una operación
antiterrorista el 24 de septiembre en
mali el presidente manuel mayor le dio
el título de oficial de la legión de
honor en medio de una sobria ceremonia
gracias por continuar con nosotros en
france 24 soy valentina torre sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos esta
emisión de noticias en eeuu donde los
demócratas lograron un acuerdo interno y
con los republicanos para aprobar el
proyecto de presupuesto fiscal con lo
que se evita el cierre parcial del
gobierno que iba a ocurrir en la
medianoche del primero de octubre el
líder demócrata en el senado chuck
schumer anunció el acuerdo para la
votación que se realizará este jueves
luego de que los demócratas aceptaran
votar por a parte del techo de la deuda
algo que previamente estaba incluido en
el mismo proyecto y a lo que se oponían
dos senadores demócratas y los
republicanos del senado para ampliar
este tema conectamos con emilio viano
les analista político internacional
experto en temas de seguridad el
profesor del departamento de justicia de
la american university bienvenido a
france 24 algo que tenemos que decir es
que previamente los demócratas se
estaban oponiendo a este a este acuerdo
estaban oponiéndose a aprobar este este
paquete cómo se llega a un acuerdo
dentro de los
bueno
dentro de los demócratas a los dos
campos hay demócratas que llamamos
progresistas que quieren
aprovechar de la presidencia de bailén
para lanzar un programa muy amplio de
digamos seguridad social para decir
expander por ejemplo medicare que es el
sistema de salud para los jubilados
invertir muchos fondos para combatir el
cambio climático
después apagar el preescolar universal
para todos los niños del país que lo
requieran así que los padres tengan esta
ayuda y pueden salir también en el
trabajo por seguir sus carreras y
también a dar dinero donde sea necesario
diversas comunidades se ayuda también a
aumentar en un cierto sentido
digamos
lahm
aumentar la intervención del gobierno en
la solución de problemas raciales de
violencia policial reforma del sistema
de ausencia para decir una una gama muy
amplia hay naturalmente demócratas que
se oponen a esto piensan que es
demasiado dinero serían tres trillones y
medio de dólares y prefieren uno u otro
programa después de un trío y medio de
dólares que se refiere más a la
infraestructura material como carreteras
puentes tuberías de plomo puertos
conexiones del internet en las áreas
rurales y montañosas
así que hay este conflicto entre los más
conservadores entre los demócratas que
están hablando más de una
infraestructura material y de los
progresistas que dicen esto está bien
pero tenemos que aprovechar para
demostrar que nosotros estamos dando
ayuda a la gente común a la clase media
y vamos naturalmente para pagar para
todo esto aumentar los impuestos para
los ricos que obtuvieron por trump un
corte de impuestos dramático señor bueno
ahora que ya hay un acuerdo entre los
republicanos y los demócratas que
significa que ya no haya un cierre del
gobierno
bueno veremos lo que pasa mañana con una
votación nunca se sabe pero pensemos que
sea así es mucho mejor y ese cierre del
gobierno crea problemas muy serios para
el país para su imagen para su
responsabilidad fiscal el mismo es para
el mercado de acciones que hoy cayó de
dos puntos
anticipando que no haría este acuerdo y
como dijo la secretaria del tesoro si
procedencia haría este será el gobierno
sería una una herida autoinfligida
es muy muy tenida al hablar la economía
de los eeuu
así que esto claro es una muy buena
noticia pero aún hay a la la la
discordia entre los demócratas y después
entre los demócratas y los republicanos
de como
y actuar sobre estos dos proyectos de
ley es la empresa infraestructura
digamos más material más fácil la
infraestructura como la calidad de vida
para los americanos que los progresistas
quieren proteger señor bueno pues a
usted muchas gracias por este análisis
por esta ampliación estaremos muy
pendientes de lo que ocurre en la
votación mañana en el senado en otras
noticias francia y reino unido- vuelven
a enfrentarse esta vez por la pesca en
aguas del canal de la mancha
londres sólo aprobó 12 de las 47
licencias pesqueras solicitadas por
comerciantes galos y parís calificó la
decisión de inaceptable el gobierno
considera que la medida infringe el
acuerdo de brek si está recordemos que
la pesca fue el principal punto de
discusión en las negociaciones de salida
de reino unido de la unión europea
francia evaluar represalias luís muñoz
más amplia
el post break 7 aumenta las tensiones
entre francia y reino unido el martes
londres anunció la aprobación de la
licencia de pesca en sus aguas
territoriales para 12 barcos franceses
de los 47 solicitantes y el miércoles la
isla de jersey dependiente de la corona
británica de negocio 35 solicitudes
galas esta decisión no ha gustado en
francia'
la respuesta es primero decir que estas
decisiones son completamente
inaceptables e inadmisibles porque
infringen el acuerdo que se firmó en el
marco del presi a la corte
entre los acuerdos del break si te
existen fricciones en dos de los tres
puntos acordados para la transición
prevista hasta 2026 entre 12 y 200
millas náuticas de la costa británica no
hay problemas estos empiezan en la
franja de 6 a 12 millas naúticas de la
costa desde el sur del mar del norte
hasta galés los buques que ya ocupaban
esa zona tienen acceso garantizado hasta
2026 sin embargo francia dice que 75
buques esperan respuesta mientras que
londres dice que son 47 distinguiendo
embarcaciones nuevas de las que ya
pescaban antes del break city por último
la mayor fuente de conflictos son las
islas del canal jersey girl y donde los
barcos franceses deben proporcionar
pruebas de 11 días de pesca entre el 1
de febrero de 2017 y el 30 de enero de
2020 los derechos de pesca fue uno de
los principales obstáculos en las
negociaciones del break sheet para reino
unido es un sector simbólico para la
unión europea representa el 40 por
ciento de la pesca de la flota europea
francia estudia respuestas contundentes
vamos a identificar y decidir cuáles son
las respuestas que vamos a dar lo que he
propuesto a los profesionales es dar o
darnos 15 días para preparar todas estas
medidas el equipo está en mayo decenas
de barcos franceses rodearon el puerto
de jersey reino unido- respondió sacando
a dos patrulleras de la armada a lo que
francia amenazó con cortar el suministro
eléctrico ayer sí que depende en un 95%
del país galo
en una ceremonia solemne francia rindió
un homenaje póstumo a maxim blasco
soldado fallecido la semana pasada en
mali el presidente manuel ma con lo
ascendió sargento y lo nombre oficial de
la legión de honor el primer ministro
jan castex y numerosos miembros del
gabinete también estuvieron presentes
cargado por sus hermanos de armas el
cuerpo del cabo mayor máxime blanco
entró a los inválidos
un solemne homenaje nacional al soldado
de 34 años asesinado en mali el viernes
pasado
blasco fue condecorado a título póstumo
por su valentía en el campo de batalla
en nombre de la república francesa lo
hacemos oficial de la legión de honor
en 2019 durante un intenso tiroteo salvo
a dos de sus compañeros luego de que su
helicóptero se estrellara durante una
operación contrainsurgente
al sepultar su cuerpo el presidente
manuel mccrone saludo a su familia
blasco deja un hijo de ocho años y a su
compañera quien ahora espera que el
presidente les conceda un matrimonio
póstumo como fisco cuando le dije a mi
hijo lo que quería lloró de alegría y se
puso muy contento me dije que esto es
importante y que es la manera de
reconstruir nuestras vidas para los
padres el dolor de perder a su hijo fue
demasiado para soportarlo pero ahora
quieren conocer a quienes lo acompañaron
en su última misión en su trabajo quiero
conocerlos porque realmente lo necesito
realmente para hablar de su hijo
es ella mismo si sobre sus últimos días
como era lo necesito para tener un
cierre de maxime blasco es el soldado
número 52 en ser asesinado en la región
de sahel desde 2013
por primera vez en la historia de túnez
una mujer será jefa de gobierno el
presidente de caixa jet eligió a nashla
wood en rondan como primera ministra dos
meses después de la suspensión del
parlamento y la destitución del anterior
gabinete esta académica con poca
experiencia política ha logrado una
elección histórica pues también es la
primera mujer en ocupar un cargo de esta
magnitud en el mundo árabe
una desconocida en el mundo político
toma las riendas del gobierno en túnez
es la primera vez que una mujer asume el
cargo de primera ministra
su nombre es más la vida en rondan de 63
años de edad el presidente hayes usaid
le encargó la tarea de formar un
gobierno lo antes posible y le recalcó
cuáles serán sus retos
el trabajo debe ser rápido y el equipo
que dirigirá debe ser homogéneo y
trabajar ante todo en la lucha contra la
corrupción
naim abu den es doctora en geología y
posee poca experiencia política pero
desde ya asumió la tarea que le fue
asignada hoy tuve el honor de ser
asignada por el presidente de caixa et
para liderar el gobierno de túnez y
determinar su composición lo antes
posible la principal tarea del nuevo
gobierno será la lucha contra la
corrupción le pedimos a dios que nos
conceda éxito su nombramiento demuestra
la desconfianza a la clase política
tradicional por parte del presidente es
ayer su llegada al cargo se da dos meses
después de la destitución de la anterior
gabinete el 25 de julio side suspendió
el parlamento y asumió los plenos
poderes desde entonces cientos de
tunecinos manifestaron su rechazo a este
golpe de fuerza y el mandatario ha
estado enfrentando una creciente presión
tanto local como internacional para
formar un ejecutivo
sin embargo el miércoles pasado shy tomó
otras medidas suspendiendo varios
capítulos de la constitución lo que le
permite gobernar por decreto dichas
medidas reforzaron sus poderes y
debilitaron los del primer ministro y es
con poderes limitados que wood él deberá
no sólo hacer frente a la corrupción
sino también a la acechante crisis
económica agravada por la pandemia y por
meses de inestabilidad política
y arribó a la isla de la palma el primer
vuelo comercial tras el cierre del
aeropuerto local debido a la erupción
continua del volcán cumbre vieja de esta
forma fue agilizada la llegada de ayudas
y también la evacuación de residentes ya
son 6.000 personas que han abandonado
sus hogares devorados por la lava los
expertos siguen monitoreando la
toxicidad de los gases que produce el
encuentro del magma con el agua del
atlántico
manuel acá no tiene los detalles
lo dejaron todo la familia de remedios
armas pérez tuvo que vivir de su hogar
con el anuncio del avance de la lava del
volcán cumbre vieja pero ahora mismo no
sé dónde está mi cada sancionados a
todos por la tele se ve un amasijo negro
yo no imagino que no sabré ubicar
físicamente
como ella más de 6000 personas fueron
evacuadas de la palma ese es también el
caso de jose alejandro santos quien
perdió su casa y gran parte de sus
pertenencias ahora vive en una caravana
como su hogar temporal al igual que sus
padres y los niños de la familia que son
albergados en pequeñas habitaciones o en
casas de familias y conocidos la
caravana hace seis meses que la
compremos y gracias gracias a esto
o pueda escapar porque estamos
prácticamente en la calle en la calle
mal mal vídeos mal bañados mal comido
muchos no han podido encontrar vivienda
a nadie si acá costa relata que toparse
que un alquiler asequible ha sido un
calvario no quiero que me regalen una
casa ahora mismo ni que me quemé
hospeden gratis sino un alquiler que yo
pueda pagar porque mi marido es
pensionista cobra 600 euros he llamado a
500.000 me piden 800 600 los expertos
advierten que la erupción no está
estabilizada por lo que el volcán podría
seguir incrementando o disminuyendo su
actividad por lo que podría haber más
damnificados llegamos así al final de
este informativo pero les recordamos que
pueden ampliar todas las noticias y
repetir estas y otras emisiones en
nuestra web france24 puntocom regresamos
en unos momentos con más información
[Música]